welcome back to the Rich Eisen show I
love this man I don't care who knows it
it is an absolute pleasure that I get to
call him a friend which he is and I
loved covering him when I was on
SportsCenter and on NFL Network and
getting to know him and his family and
who he is
and he's one of my favorites and anytime
I say hey would you like to come on the
show he answers and his name is Brett
Favre
how are you Brett I'm good rich thanks
for having you got it had Elway on last
hour Brett I had that weigh on last hour
okay all right so now we're at Tucker
okay now I don't know where to go I you
know what Super Bowl or golf did you see
him talking about your golf game in his
golf game did you see that portion of
the interview no okay because I
mentioned I'm sure it was pretty painful
well you know I told him what you shot
yesterday and he asked if that if that
number was accurate it was very accurate
okay and believe me there was a time I
shooting in the 70s was not out of the
realm of my game
I absolutely suck so 79 yesterday was
was quite an accomplishment I I really
don't play hardly any anymore
okay well you know he said Elway that's
been a while since he's played and then
throughout that he's a 1 handicap
just real casual which I was very
impressed with that flex right now you
know he's a he's a heck of an athlete I
know that let's give him the benefit of
the doubt I know that I'll be playing
too much golf he's got work to do I know
he said he hasn't played very much the
other thing that he mentioned about your
history and relationship is that you
nailed his walk down perfectly at Pro
Bowls oh yeah pretty easy is that how
you become a Hall of Fame quarterback is
that what kids need to do is start
walking pigeon-toed well I know too that
it worked out well for you got a good
you got a good Elway story from that
Super Bowl at all Brett anything else
that you you remember
John there's only thing that comes to
mind is in John and I Jen you know
John's a little bit over than I but but
we've done quarterback challenges
together we won't Disney World with both
families together and I do considering
month a good friend so when they beat us
after the game get showered and you know
obviously I wasn't in the best of moods
but I go out to the bus and both teams
it was at San Diego both teams come out
of the same area same tunnel and you
know there's a lot of players and
Packers lot of players from the from the
Broncos kind of staying around to all
kind of families and friends and I'm on
the bus I see John so I go down get off
the bus and just go or save John man you
know I was and obviously was in not a
foul mood just just you know
disappointed I said hey man
congratulations he said hey don't be so
down just matter of fact sit don't be so
down Yuri won one is about time I got
one I was like okay I get that I went
back on the bus and kept licking my
wounds but now John you know we always
had a great relationship he you know he
played really well on that game but it
was not really John Elway esque and I
mean that with no disrespect they just
didn't really need surprisingly Terrell
Davis was just sure killing it you know
and that was his hometown there in San
Diego and that was it I just remember
though that it seemed like you know
Green Bay that let let Denver score so
you could get the ball back and trying
well and we did and we had a chance
right true we did we you know that was
the only one where we let Terrell Davis
do anything the rest of his might did it
on us home and it was a it was a good
strategy we got the ball we had a chance
we drove down to effect about 50
and turn it over on downs so I mean it
was it was a good move really our only
move based on the fact that we couldn't
stop drill all day is best
we just hoped that he would actually
score and give us that shot did somebody
have to explain to Reggie white what the
plan was I mean did somebody have to
basically tell the Minister of Defence
stand down no Reggie Reggie smartest
players one of the greatest players have
placed you're not the greatest but one
of the smartest and he got it and they
are our guys are so worn down because
they just just pounded it on us all day
it you know it's been a long time but I
think people refresh your memory they
would agree it was a slugfest that
featured Terrell Davis you know and I've
never asked you this question and maybe
I should ask it of the coach but I'll
ask it here anyway would home would have
gone for - to win it do you think if you
scored the touchdown do you know I don't
know the answer that question my guess
would be he wasn't kicked the extra
point yeah and then taking our chances
hoping maybe we got the ball first or
something right you know I've never I
gotta ask him that next time he's on
here Brett Favre here on the Rich Eisen
show okay Brett let's let's get into you
know the story that's really still
resonating from the draft and it's
interesting that it happened I think a
half an hour after you left our draft
Athan live room on on draft night which
I really appreciate you spending a full
hour joining us to help raise money for
Cova 19 relief that night but it was the
drafting of Jordan Love by the Green Bay
Packers and I wonder what you thought of
that move by Green Bay obviously with
the history of between you and there and
the team well I'll be honest with you I
was very surprised
I really thought today would go in the
direction of an offensive weapon you
know there were several plays from from
being in Super Bowls
you know the game of life but you know
just a few plays they kind of fall back
in that game and
in nothing against Jordan love it have
not I mean no disrespect but you trade
up to get a guy who he may turn out to
be great I hope he does but you to trade
up to get a a more of a project you know
the he's all been unproven a lot of
upside no doubt about it but it can't
help you get to the Super Bowl
immediately and I just think that if
you're playing for now and all the teams
in the league will tell you they are or
most will tell you that some certainly
or not but greenbags one of them that
should should be playing for now they
don't draft any weapons not just in the
first round but any weapons that can
help immediately to my knowledge and
that just sends a disrespect message to
what I would think to Aaron Rodgers he
he has every right to be disappointed if
he is yeah I was about if he is any
indication I mean he really had the only
indication is that he has called Jordan
love or connected with Jordan love and
congratulated him and welcomed into the
team and that they have connected that's
the word that Brian gudykunst use that
they have connected and management and
Rogers well Aaron and I get along great
and I did talk to him I Michael talked
about all that we talked about but he he
was let's just say surprise that that
they went in that direction and I'm not
surprised that he reached out to Jordan
being in a similar situation himself
fifteen years ago and we had a great
relationship in spite of what now I
wouldn't say it took a turn for the
worst when I left but he was basically
caught up in the middle of a hornet's
nest if you will I don't foresee that
happening here I think I think Aaron
will do whatever you know it's not his
job to mentor Jordan love and this
discussion went on you know when I left
Green Bay it's not that
head guys job to mentor the next guy
that guy is ultimately there to take
your spot now if Jordan were to ask
Aaron can i watch extra film with you I
would be shocked if Aaron said no you
know I think he would go over and beyond
help but he's not go out of his way and
that's I can't blame you so uh getting
back to winning now and the importance
of having the pieces in place or almost
all the pieces in place and you you
selecting not only in the first round
but other rounds other positions other
than an immediate needs for our offenses
uh to me it just sends the wrong message
that we're preparing for the future now
rather than we're gonna try to win this
thing next year Brett Favre Pro Football
Hall of Famer here on the Rich Eisen
show well one of the reasons why Aaron
might be surprised or have been
surprised by it is by all accounts the
Packers didn't give him a heads up that
when they're trading up it was for for
love did you get the Ted Thompson never
reach out to you back in the day that
didn't happen huh
you know I don't think I think that
probably pretty rare I'm not gonna say
it other quarterbacks have not been in
the know on who they're drafting or or
even asked opinions so for example if
Ted Thompson were to call me back in the
day and say look we're thinking about
drafting a quarterback to the first
round what do you think of this guy that
would seem odd you know I don't know I
don't know if it's commonplace to
include players on advice or you know
advice maybe you know maybe okay
like we're thinking about this receiver
you liking yeah I do okay I just wanted
to get your take on him or a trade but I
don't think it's too common practice to
you know to include the players on who
they're try
and their opinions well I'm not just I'm
not just saying that I guess the way I
would go is that hey you know Aaron you
know we're on the clock now all of a
sudden I just wanted to give you a call
the journal entry well that's what I'm
saying is that say he's not sitting
there watching
I'm sure NFL Network instead of ESPN but
I'm sure that he would be sitting so
he's not sitting there and then
wondering where the hell did that come
from
that he does at least have a 10-minute
heads-up or five minute heads-up you
know while somebody might be on the
phone with Jordan love somebody's on the
phone with Aaron Rodgers you know that
that's the one thing that I I was
wondering you know taking that if I were
the GM and I had Drew Brees if I had Tom
Brady if I had Aaron Rodgers Russell
Wilson guys like that oh my as my
quarterback
I would I would make sure that I gave
every impression that I their input was
extremely valuable and that whatever I
did I was doing the best interest of the
team but I wanted to include them you
know I just think that that I mean Green
Bay's not going anywhere without Aaron
Rodgers and the next year if he plays
like we expected to play they got a shot
with or without a first round receiver
he's that good so I would do all I could
to not burn that bridge and I I don't
think that they did that I think that
they burned a bridge that it's going to
be hard to overcome at some point I
think it will rear its ugly head how so
Brett what do you mean he's got four
years left on his contract out you know
I mean say they started off forward
three regards hi Aaron's playing but I
assume he'll play like he normally does
but there are three I think we'll see
the claws come out from from mulatto
folks
and they're gonna be left trying to
defend themselves if that makes sense
no I doctors no I guess so I hear you I
mean so I I just don't know how ready
love really is that was part of the
evaluation right is that right now I
mean look again no disrespect that yeah
I know that the trade up for an unproven
really unknown tremendous potential but
you know a lot of question marks you
know that he's not really any
quarterback you drafted in the first
round with Aaron Rodgers is not going to
see the field anytime soon
and it's not going to help you win a
Super Bowl next year I wouldn't think
now unless they you know they just think
that there's absolutely no chance we'll
ever get a talent like this ever again
in the next five years but he's got four
years left on his contract Aaron does
and are you going to draft someone in
the first round and let him sit for five
years give them a new contract without
even even see in the field or enough to
really make a decision one way or the
other and getting what big contract yeah
anyway sure he's gonna have a contract
in five years yeah well and for really
if it's a five-year deal I don't know I
don't know how the rookie contract play
out anymore but no it's the same way
you're right is that there there will
have to be some form of an evaluation a
big deal without saying play that that
ultimately is what's going to happen are
they from being a situation where they
just cut bait and allow Aaron to go play
somewhere else somewhat similar to my
situation so in the X's and O's be able
to keep them happy in the short term
right and in terms of the X's and O's
you know we had a very respected
evaluator and Greg Cosell he's NFL Films
and and so many other entities that he
as one of the top in the game saying
that Rodgers plays out of the construct
of what Lafleur and others might want
and that love and the drafting of love
is potentially an indication if Lafleur
said but Lafleur believes Rogers
won't do because he does leave some
plays on the field within the construct
of what the coaching staff wants to do
and that was his evaluation of the love
pick in the prism of Rodgers would you
agree with something like that Brett I
guess I wouldn't disagree but I don't
know I meant Leflore one time but you
know our situation is so similar at this
point our careers new coach new
organization you know the the regime
that drafted Aaron is gone completely
gone and it's a new regime that's the
same thing that happened with me and so
it's kind of I my take is we want to put
our stamp on our guys and hope that we
can win with previous guys meaning aaron
rodgers and some other guys i don't
think that i mean they'd be idiots to
think that aaron is not capable of
leading them to a super bowl but it's
proven that he can't do it alone and but
they're gonna they're gonna rest on on
that assumption that he can get us there
we're doing you know i don't know if we
got better for next year never I don't
know if they're gonna do a free agency
or any any moves between now then but it
just to me they're placing a lot of
there and which is fine it was Aaron but
it but it but it from from a
relationship standpoint it sends the
wrong message and I think this again
when adversity hits this year oh and
three couple bad games or whatever that
it's career its ugly head and you know
the daggers are gonna be out so I guess
my last one for you bread and it's it's
a difficult question but I'm gonna ask
it certainly more trouble difficult to
answer since it's looked in the future
it's the old crystal ball and you even
said yourself like the world you do you
cut me off yeah you think he will not
end his career as a Green Bay Packers
you oh my gut tells me no you know it's
kind of cool now too
it's not uncommon to retire and retire
now if you know what I did it right it
was a little bit pallid the realm now
it's fairly common not just in football
but in all sports and it's you know Tom
Brady and myself and Joe Montana and
Peyton Manning but - just to name a few
that's finish their career elsewhere and
in my case I played before different
teams so I think that that's them you
don't see that trend Lord more now I
think hearing will finish somewhere else
that's my gut yeah I mean because again
it's it is crazy how similar this is now
happening it's it is I guarantee you
this and I don't know this certain but I
guarantee you it's got the wheels
turning and Aaron's mind which which if
that's the case and that means that
there's a chip on his shoulder towards
the organization that otherwise was not
there and so he all he needs is a reason
other than this reason to expedite that
Brett appreciate the time man love you
best to your family best everybody
everybody good your hair still died okay
and I noticed by the way you had that
gaming headset on on Thursday night at
draft a thon live he was like are you a
game or two you do an eSports Brett and
your spare time and the last time I play
the game was you'll appreciate this was
Atari and I was great in pac-man and
Space Invaders so he called okay so
that's a no then that's not a demon
headset for you but maybe for somebody
else in the household that's fantastic
yeah you
because I look important it looked great
look great and thanks for do I mean ton
of money got raised just I love the
conversation between you and Deon - from
back in the day and the Falcons it was
great me too
thanks again Bret you take care of
yourself best your family I race you too
man you the man we'll do it again I love
it that's a Brett Favre
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here